going to teach you leg kick and the
fundamentals behind how to kick
somebody's leg Yeah if you and I fight
I'm going to chop your legs out from
underneath you all you do is talk about
this footwork your Taekwondo days yeah
not anymore Taekwondo it's what taquanda
one more time
Taekwondo Brian thinks he can kick or
you think you know what to do with the
light cake well so every time he steps
knock knock
yeah that doesn't feel good it doesn't
feel good so you're kicking me that way
what are you you're right right here on
the teardrop right right where your your
quad's end so I see a lot of guys
checking you can check and when I'm
turning inside somebody can step in and
count and that's where you do something
so if you go to the account if you go to
kick me I'm stepping into town yeah
because guess what this ends the fight
not that why don't guys jump what'd you
say why don't guys jump jump why waste
time with checking you gonna kick me I'm
gonna jump in the air bang like that and
that's the end of the fight so